hallo leute heute rede ich über fehler
die man machen kann wenn man deutschland
ich treffe immer wieder menschen die
deutsch lernen ich trete euch unsere
zuschauer ich treffe freunde die deutsch
lernen und ich bin auch mit einem mann
verheiratet nämlich janus der deutsch
gelernt hat und aus diesen begegnungen
habe ich einige tipps aufgeschrieben
oder fehler gesehen die man vermeiden
sollte wenn man anfängt deutsch zu
lernen
los geht's ein fehler den man unbedingt
vermeiden sollte wenn man anfängt
deutsch zu lernen ist die nomen ohne
artikel zu lernen
ihr wisst wahrscheinlich schon dass es
im deutschen drei artikel gibt der die
das und immer wenn man ein nomen in
einem anderen fall setzen möchte wenn
man also dekliniert dann benötigt man
die artikel
das ist der baum aber ich stehe an dem
baum das heißt ich verändere nicht die
nomen in einem anderen fall sondern die
artikel und ich kenne einige leute die
haben deutsch gelernt einfach so auf der
straße durch das sprechen und haben
nicht darauf geachtet diese artikel mit
zu lernen sie haben sich nur die nomen
ohne artikel gemerkt und haben
irgendwann schwierigkeiten diese
thematik richtig zu benutzen und das
kann ganz interessant sein irgendwann
weil man kann sich schon ausdrückt man
kann alles sagen alle verstehen sich
aber trotzdem wirst du in jedem
einzelnen satz einen grammatikfehler
machen und das möchtest du
wahrscheinlich nicht deshalb solltest du
von anfang an die artikel mit dem nomen
lernen dass es nicht nur kamera sondern
das ist wie kamera ein weiterer
populärer fehler hat mit trennbaren
werben zu tun trennbare werben sind ein
konzept dass ihr vielleicht nicht direkt
am anfang lernt aber irgendwann
vielleicht bei a2 oder b1 spätestens
lernt ihr diese werben kennen
im deutschen gibt es werden die x
wenn sie konjugiert werden trennt ein
beispiel ist weg gehen
im infiniti iv ist das ein wort aber im
satz konjugiert sind es zwei wörter ich
gehe weg und das ist tatsächlich ein
fehler den janisch auch manchmal heute
noch nach 30 jahren macht janisch hat
zum beispiel neulich gesagt ich setze
mir gassi
korrekt müsste dieser satz heißen ich
setze den kaffee auf das wert ist
aufsetzen aufsetzen und setzten klingen
ähnlich aber sie sind zwei komplett
unterschiedliche werben mit
unterschiedlichen bedeutungen und was
ihr euch merken könnt ist dass ihr diese
beiden werden jeweils als eigenes werk
lernt merkt euch nicht kaffee ist
irgendwas mit setzen sondern merkt euch
aufsetzen ist das vollständige werk hier
ist noch ein weiteres beispiel
hier sehen wir ein foto von janisch und
demi und janisch hat dieses foto
folgendermaßen kommentiert alter wir
sehen wie sie sieht ob die amish hat
gesagt alter wir sehen wie sie sie topf
aber sehen ist nicht das werk das er
benutzen wollte das vollständige wert
ist aussehen aussehen is to look like
sehen ist für sie also es sind auch im
englischen zwei unterschiedliche werben
organisch hat die präposition am ende
vergessen und dadurch ein ganz anderes
wert benutzt also noch mal merkt euch
das vollständige werk mit präposition
denn es ist ein anderes werk als es ohne
präposition wäre
immer wenn ich menschen treffe die
deutsch lernen frage ich sie als
allererstes was ist deine motivation
deutsch zu lernen und dann höre ich ganz
unterschiedliche antworten zum beispiel
du hast einen partner aus deutschland
du hast freunde in deutschland du
möchtest in deutschland studieren oder
vielleicht möchtest du in
schlund arbeiten alle von euch haben so
einen haupt motivationsgrund wenn es
darum geht die deutsche sprache zu
lernen
aber bei vielen menschen höre ich auch
dass es diesen punkt gibt wo man diese
motivation in frage stellt ihr alle habt
einen moment wo ihr vielleicht nicht
weiterkommt beim lernen oder wo ihr
licht die fortschritte macht die ihr
gerne machen möchte und dann fragt ihr
euch plötzlich muss ich wirklich deutsch
lernen für meinen partner
wo da können wir einfach englisch
sprechen wie wir das jetzt auch schon
tun diese frage ist wichtig ich stelle
mir diese frage auch wenn ich polnisch
lernen zb nur mechanische in berlin zu
leben ist für mich nicht genug
motivation polnisch zu lernen und mir
ist klar wenn ich wirklich die sprache
lernen will dann brauche ich noch eine
andere motivation dann müssen wir öfter
nach polen fahren oder ich muss etwas in
polen finden was ich mag und das ist der
tipp den ich an euch habe sucht euch von
anfang an etwas was euch motiviert und
am besten sind das mehrere sachen das
können filme seien musik das können
bücher seien die ihr mit dass können
bestimmte orte sein die ihr immer wieder
besucht an denen ihr euch wohl fühlt das
können freunde seien in dem land
all das ist wichtig damit ihr in diesen
momenten wo es euch nicht so gut geht
oder wo er nicht vorankommt mehr als nur
eine motivation habt eine sprache zu
lernen
der vierte fehler den ihr verwaltet wenn
ihr deutschland ist davon auszugehen
dass deutsch lernen so funktioniert wenn
es um euren fortschritt und eure
motivation geht akzeptiert dass es
passive lernphasen gibt ihr alle werdet
diesen punkt haben wo ihr denkt ich habe
jetzt einen großen fortschritt im
deutsch gemacht aber genau so werdet ihr
eine zeit haben wo ihr denkt jetzt habe
ich wochenlang gar keinen fortschritt
gemacht oder vielleicht denkt ihr sogar
ich glaube ich habe mein deutsch
verloren
ich habe einen schritt zurück gemacht in
diesen momenten dürft ihr nicht aufgeben
denn diese momente hat weg
nicht jeder mensch in jeder sprache die
er lernt und in diesen momenten
passierten mehr als ihr denkt es ist
nicht so dass man immer sich aktiv
verbessert oder dass es so läuft es
läuft manchmal so aber auch in diesen
passiven phase ist es wichtig dass ihr
euch bewusst sein dass das eine gute
zeit ist und dass diese zeit auch zu
eurem lernen beiträgt was helfen kann
ist eine routine
zum beispiel indem ihr euch einen plan
setzt der realistisch ist jeden tag
mache ich 15 minuten deutsch oder alle
zwei tage mache ich eine stunde deutsch
es ist wichtig dass der plan realistisch
ist damit ihr ihn nicht so schnell
aufgibt und wenn ihr gute zeiten habt
dann macht euch diese routine glücklich
wenn er schlechte zeiten habt dann kann
euch diese routine retten
denn ihr werdet dann nicht so schnell
aufgeben ihr werdet einfach an ihrem
plan festhalten
das war mein vierter jetzt bin ich super
gespannt von euch zu hören was eure
erfahrungen sind was sind die fehler die
er gemacht habt was sind die tipps die
ihr anderen geben könnte schreibt uns
einen kommentar hier unter das video und
schaut auch bei instagram vorbei den
link findet ihr hier unten in unseren
instagram stories werden wir auch diese
konversation mit euch weiterführen
außerdem könnt ihr sie german
unterstützen mit nur einem dollar pro
woche bekommt ihr jede woche vokabeln
und übungen zu unseren videos und
außerdem sollte die isar germany
monieren
danke fürs zuschauen und bis zur
nächsten woche